House Republicans are divided tonight
over impeachment proceedings against the
number-two official in the Justice
Department chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge looks
at both sides tonight
do I support impeachment of rod Rosen
Stein no I do not the House speaker
characterized the articles of
impeachment filed by the house freedom
caucus as an extreme static I don't
think we should be cavalier with this
process or with this term I don't think
that this rises the level of high crimes
and misdemeanors among the allegations
the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein has a conflict of interest
overseeing the Russia probe because he
signed the final surveillance warrant
for Trump campaign aide Carter page
based in part on the unverified Trump
dossier months earlier the former
British spy behind the dossier
Christopher Steele was fired by the FBI
for lying
Steele also admitted his hatred for
candidate Trump according to the
articles of impeachment quote Deputy
Attorney General Rosen Stein's failure
to recuse himself in light of this
inherent conflict of interest constitute
dereliction of duty it was very
frustrating to hear the speaker call our
efforts Cavalier Christopher Steele lied
to the FBI rod Rosenstein knew that and
was so Cavalier that he thought that his
information was still a basis to spy on
people associated with the Trump
campaign Democrats claimed the goal is
discrediting Special Counsel Robert
Muller's brusha probe just when you
think you have seen it all the
Republicans have no shame to go to a
place where they would undermine our
judicial system if it's in the service
of this president that's all they care
about a charge one key Republican denies
I haven't discussed it with the
president and so I can tell you at this
who the president higher z' and fires is
certainly not going to be influenced by
something that this member of Congress
does in Boston the Attorney General said
House Republicans should refocus and
defended the department's number two my
deputy rod Rosen Stein is highly capable
I have the highest confidence in him we
need Congress to deal with the
immigration question the Justice
Department fails to provide the withheld
records the Republican aides said
tonight they have a commitment from
leadership to hold a vote on a contempt
resolution after the recess in early
September insisting impeachment remains
on the table Mike Catherine Herridge
thanks very much